you know whenever i see a new video game
adaptation i'm always wondering how long
it'll be before i rage quit the [ __ ] you
say to me a little [ __ ] but holy [ __ ] i
think i can officially say it arcane is
the best video game adaptation ever
created granted that isn't a huge part
to overcome but this show is damn good
with slick animation a kick-ass score
and characters we actually care about so
in this video we'll be covering arcane's
ending character lore and theories for
season 2. oh god please let there be a
season two i mean the ceo of riot did
tweet out they're committed to multiple
seasons and this is a tweet from 2019. i
also have tons of theories on what might
happen after that disastrous rocket
attack plus i'm hoping you caught that
not-so-hidden clue that we could see the
return of vander and new characters like
orianna stick around to the end of the
video for that but before we get into it
consider playing support this round by
clicking the like and subscribe button
my elo is abysmally low and i'm just
trying to get out of bronze 5. the final
episode is the last chapter in arkane's
three act structure it's titled the
monster you created but who is this
monster well the title is a reference to
many there's jinx who was created by
vi's abandonment and silco's
manipulation silco himself a byproduct
of a people left unwanted and uncared
for by its ruling elite singed burned
and disfigured by the illicit drug
shimmer in episode 3 victor who mixes
shimmer and hex tech to prolong his life
and me horribly scarred that'll have to
wait at least a year for season 2. jace
laments the death of a child he killed
during a raid on one of silco's shimmer
facilities but vai is quick to remind
him that's nothing compared to the
hundreds killed by silco's actions since
silco took control of the undercity
after the death of vander in episode 3
crime drugs and violence has exploded
turning many of its citizens into
shimmer junkies jace perhaps naively
believes he can broker a peace deal with
silko but each side demands something
neither is likely to give up for example
jace wants jinx handed over to him jinx
was responsible for several attacks over
the course of episodes 4 to 9 including
an attack which left several enforcers
including sheriff marcus dead as we
learned later on in the episode silco
never had any intention of turning jinx
over for him it would be like turning
over his own daughter i never would have
given you to them
not for anything the same can be said
for silco's demands he wanted free trade
routes blanket amnesty access to the hex
gates and most importantly sovereignty
this would establish the nation of zan
something he fought for his entire life
he could have had that nation but his
love for jinx was stronger but before we
get more into that silco has to deal
with a coup within his criminal
organization finn believes silko is weak
the undercity has grown chaotic under
his rule and it's time for a change he
even has another member on his side
rennie who was the mother of the boy
jace killed silco gives a speech about
loyalty how that was the only thing that
got him and the others through the dark
days of the past and as it looks like
silko's days are numbered cevica ends up
killing finn perhaps out of loyalty
civica will later fight vai where she
gets her arm ripped off and thrown into
the jukebox the same jukebox player that
starts every episode but what i really
want to discuss is the last shot we see
of her she's in silko's office lighting
her cigar with finn's lighter silko's
chair is empty in the background
suggesting she will be the one to take
over with silko dead at the end of the
episode the underground doesn't have a
leader and she just might be the one to
step up victor is reeling from the death
of sky the two had a high school-like
romance over the course of the season
and she ended up disintegrating when
trying to help victor release himself
from the now corrupted hex core victor's
experiments let him down a dangerous
path where he ended up taking shimmer
and combining it with hextech to prolong
his life it's kind of ironic since his
mentor singe did similar nefarious
experiments in order to prolong the life
of his pet rio in both instances someone
they loved was killed victor is so
overcome with grief and the decisions
that he's made over the season that he
even contemplates suicide before jace
interrupts him skye's letter to him
talked about how he's made the world a
better place but for him he thinks he's
just made it worse he even tries to
break the corrupted hextech but is
unable to but we're not exactly sure if
this is because he's linked to it or
just doesn't have the courage the last
two episodes also see the introduction
of embessa medarda who appears to be a
prominent member of the noxus empire one
of league of legends many factions and
bessa sent her daughter mel to piltover
because she thought she lacked spine
embezza also says of mel you weakened me
i couldn't endure the look in your eyes
whenever i made the decisions the
necessary decisions to keep us safe in
ambassador's mind a ruler must be quote
a fox and a wolf both cunning and strong
and melt certainly is cunning but as we
see in episode 8's intro she lacks the
cutthroat nature her mother is looking
for mel paints a large mural of the
immortal bastion fortress surrounded by
noxus ships furthering her connection
with the empire but in one of the
season's final scenes we see she's
ruined it symbolic of her turning her
back on her mother and the empire we
also get word that mel's brother has
died but it's never mentioned who he
could be this is likely jay madarda a
playable card from the legends of
roonterra and heir apparent to the
medarda fortune jace tells victor that
they must destroy the hexcore its power
if in the wrong hands could cause
absolute devastation the potential for
this technology to be used against them
is something heimerdinger warned them of
several times heimerdinger is several
hundred years old and can recall times
in which magic nearly destroyed the
world no one heeds heimerdinger's
warnings and he's eventually kicked off
the council teaming up with a now
grown-up echo in his team of rebels
known as the firelights this
heimerdinger echo combo may be the
biggest clue as to what happens in the
wake of jinx's rocket attack but i'll
get to that in a bit silko drinks his
sorrows beneath a statue of vander a man
who was like a brother to him they both
wanted the same thing to see a world
where the people of zan could live free
just like the people topside but they
differed in how to achieve this silco
believed violence was the answer and
vander did not this
it's not gonna solve your problems
it just makes more of them it culminated
in the two duking it out with silko
almost drowning to death now silko
drinks alone living with the fact his
dream of an independent zone is right in
front of him but knowing he can't do
what it takes to achieve it that is give
up jinx after vander gave up life to
protect vi and powder jinx's name as a
child silko took in jinx and raised her
as his own since then jinx has done
silko's bidding but leaving her sister
vai abandoned her but later in the
series jinx overhears what really
happened those many years ago and
struggles with who is telling the truth
does she believe her sister or the man
who raised her but it seems jinx is too
far gone she's haunted by the voices of
her past pushing her in different
directions and silco fearing vaya's
swing jinx into madness grabs a nearby
pistol and aims now this is up to
interpretation but i believe he was
pointing the gun at vi to get her to
stop talking and jinx overcome by the
instinct to protect her sister shoots
silco in the process it's a terribly
tragic ending i should also mention
before we continue that caitlyn is also
here she gets knocked out by jinx but
it's been subtly hinted that vi and
caitlyn might eventually end up together
i thought i'd bring it up because i know
someone in the comments definitely will
in the lore the two eventually do become
partners in law enforcement so it's
definitely possible in the season's
final moments we get a montage of
various characters which lead up to
jinx's rocket attack and there's a ton
of cool stuff to unpack here that may
give us clues for season 2. the first is
jinx's decision to sit in the chair
marked jinx confirming her complete
transformation from powder to jinx there
was another chair that said powder yet
she chose to sit in this one like a
throne she has fully embraced the path
ahead of her the second thing is this
giant full moon not only does it look
badass but it may also tie into the
quick shot of singed in his lab why
werewolves here we can see this
claw-like figure hanging from the
ceiling which if you compare it to the
official artwork from riot appears to be
warwick and there are several hints
throughout the season that warwick is
vander transformed when jinx
hallucinates we see this wolf-like
drawing around his body in episode 1
vander is referred to as the hound of
the underworld so you're vander
hound of the underground plus warwick's
official bio says the following though
many think of warwick as no more than a
beast buried beneath the fury lies the
mind of a man a gangster who put down
his blade and took up a new name to live
a better life but no matter how hard he
tried to move on he could never escape
the sins of the past i could definitely
see this vander warwick plotline coming
in season 2. then there's this pocket
watch singed holds inside a picture of a
girl this could be orianna who once was
a young girl but after a tragic accident
in the lower districts her body was
replaced piece by piece both characters
seem to have the same bun hairstyle and
it would make sense that singed has a
picture of her in a pocket watch
considering orianna is comprised of
clockwork speaking of clocks and time
did you notice this device in the shot
between echo and heimerdinger echo is a
character known to manipulate time
through his own invention the z drive i
wasn't sure if this was the beginnings
of that invention or part of his flying
skateboard but regardless his ability to
turn back time may be one of several
theories that saves jace mel and victor
from the rocket attack but let's say
that's not what happens there are
several juicy possibilities out there
i'm gonna list them all here and you can
decide which ones you think make the
most sense one theory is that mel
medarda is a magic user prior to the
attack she takes off her ring a ring
which can be purchased as riot
merchandise hinting that she's probably
not going anywhere and there are even
rumors she may be an upcoming champion
also right before the attack mel
experiences this sort of spider sense as
the back of her gold dress glows now
this could simply be the reflection of
the rocket but it is nighttime i'm kind
of unsure on this one let me know what
you think below then there's jace we saw
how jace was given one of these
gemstones that allowed him and his
mother to teleport when he was a child
that could be a possibility there's also
this shield he can create with his
hammer let's also not forget about
victor who is also at this meeting this
is a guy who almost killed himself this
episode it isn't far-fetched to think he
may sacrifice himself he is or at least
was dying after all he's also known to
carry shimmer in his cane and we know
that shimmer has healing properties time
travel magic shimmer and hextech are all
possible theories as to where season 2
might kick off but i want to hear your
thoughts and theories in the comments
below i friggin loved arcane and if you
did too remember to like and subscribe
so more people can see this video thanks
for watching everyone for more bad takes
you can follow me on twitter and
instagram at thinkstoryyt until next
time remember daddy loves you very much